I'm here again with Dan Russell and that
last one was too easy shortest us
president we found it in like two
seconds that's right
forgive me something harder okay let's
try a more difficult question where
you're comparing say the population goes
to two countries okay so let's look at
for example the population growth over
the past five years of India perceive
the United States India versus so you
want me to answer I guess you just find
out how they grow or compare yeah
exactly which has had the highest rate
of growth over the past five years I
would guess it's India but we'll see how
by how much population population growth
I would write us versus India okay it's
a reasonable search all right US versus
if future fertility and immigration may
play major roles in the nation's growth
let's see now look at that as we were
talking about last time that's what that
scribed described would you believe a
result from scribed or not I don't know
I'm actually that's a web survey even
described like a well known site it's
it's so it's a pretty well known site oh
it is okay so maybe maybe it is
crowd-sourced
type of thing yeah yeah okay so let's
see okay so this oh this is some kind of
like presentation by someone that's what
scribe does yeah oh they allow you to
put your presentations on well that's
usually India's estimated population be
1.2 billion by 2010 in DPM the second
country in the world I just ran across
the 1 billion to sex ratio number of
females per thousand male's published
was 933 2.4 okay all right two other
categories okay you can look here now
yeah quite well we need two more the
ends yeah I'm feeling like I'm hitting a
date yeah I mean it might be in here
someplace but this doesn't seem like
it's an important point for doing these
kinds of searches yeah don't want to get
stuck in a rathole
yeah I want to be able to sort of you
know someone's collected this
information yeah yeah need to find it
effects of growing populations comparing
population or that looks good that looks
great discuss by set visualizing
economics and this sounds like what you
want it looks like a legitimate site I
don't know you know and she even has a
legitimate name Katherine mol Brandon
sounds very sound support yes
okay let's see so this this looks pretty
good
what wait let me see then we get rid of
this little thing that's popping up
mm-hmm okay so what is this it's
population growth over the last 500
years okay so this might not be as
granular roping okay it's an interesting
point you need not just the information
but the kind of information you're like
yeah so over 500 years it does this does
and this is actually just giving the
absolute number so we're really
concerned more as almost the the slope
of this line that's right more than the
the percentage kind of eyeball it and
see that u.s. is growing a little slower
there's a lower it was like it'd be nice
to have the resolution to actually tell
right right and actually a percentage
stuck because a percent of slightly
different than slope so it's it's it's
and this is actually only until 2000
right this is only until 2000 so I mean
the simple answer we're getting hints
that it probably is what we thought it
was that India is going faster but so at
this point I'd go back and try another
result yeah see actually growth China
versus India so let me maybe I could
just do them separately okay so
population that's actually an excellent
idea because sometimes it's easier to
find a single piece of data yeah and
then collect that and then compare it
with the other single piece of data
yeah we've been also with someone
happened to write like a write treatise
on the population growth of and we have
the Wikipedia article about the
demographics of India that sounds like
it's gonna give you the answer
let's see don't help me too much okay so
India's estimated one point four one
percent growth rate in 2009 that's right
all right so maybe we can at least let
me maybe the the u.s. one will have the
same yeah look up demographics of so
it's kind of a search within Wikipedia
that's right let's really mix it up it's
a good point wikipedia has its own
search so you never have to leave
Wikipedia there are reasons why you
sometimes want to do that the United
States
I should demographics but maybe they are
there is demographics of the United
States yeah what you wanted
yep okay so let's see but it's not the
same identical article so they don't
right okay so I'll just remember that
was one point four percent for and now
in fairness of being search agnostic I
was doing a little bit of being
the Google now let's try that all right
so let me do so let me think
okay so US population growth that was
that's at one point four into 2000 so I
wanted to point out one thing real quick
back up just a little bit okay in your
query go all the way back to population
keep going keep going keep going okay
now stop huh you see the graph right
there at the very top yeah Alysha United
States click on that and what you should
end up is in the Google public data
Explorer
oh yes exactly the graph we were looking
for for the United States if you look on
the left hand side which you should
always check because there's often
useful things there you might be able to
change for example the pop us here this
is within the United States
yeah but I'm willing to bet since we've
got this public data stuff that you
could compare India versus the US okay
so this is this is all within the US I
mean if I click chart needs more
information pop page in the US how do i
navigate this is a good look up there
yeah public data public data oh this is
needed like the hands rustling exactly
exactly this is all lots of different
kinds of collected data and you want is
something about world population world
so these are the sources
that's the sources so the World
Resources Institute sounds like someone
who would have world that's what I would
click on first world data okay but now
we've got greenhouse gases what metrics
would be more useful metrics as opposed
to where you know I so let's see Oh II
CD fatback yeah that or a World Economic
Forum okay one of those things yeah oh
but this isn't this isn't actually gonna
plot it for us
well once we go inside the data that's
what it does this is public data that's
collected and allows you to visualize it
okay with either the line graph like we
saw before or with like the Hans Rosling
the elbow chart the other thing with
this for me this seems I kind of feel
like going back to the searches okay
let's go back to this instead of I I
feel like I could dig in there for a
long time and the search seemed or you
can click right there in that search tab
and they don't take right back to Google
yep there you go so if we go US
population
relation growth by year that looks
pretty good because then we could negati
what does the npg then then npg well
we'll figure that in a second but this
is good percent change right and then
this is by year Oh this only goes up to
1998 so I'm it's probably not that
different but we could you know it's
lower than India's which is 1.4 percent
in 2009 estimated that's right but let's
see let's see let's see if we can get
something firm so let me look up the
input 2009 there 2009 and you're at us
news calm I mean that's that seems like
a legitimate site estimate okay so here
you go we have all the numbers we need
to figure out the percentage population
added since January 1 2008 and then so
this is what hat what added over I guess
this is added over 2008 right so you
could do the math at this point yes yeah
you know you might also try modifying
the query and add for example the word
percentage yes so I don't have to do the
math right percentage percentage let's
see US population growth is amongst the
highest and this is an interesting
article right so I could just search let
me search in that so I'll do a ctrl F to
search within there huh so what is it
was it population growth okay it's the
vast majority okay the u.s. shows
population increases 0.91% for the 12
month periods ending July 2011 so that's
pretty good I mean to answer your
question I think we're feeling pretty
good
India is above 1% the u.s. is below 1 by
a lot that's right so so we're and as we
know from compounding interest exactly
you're in a higher place over many many
over 10 years you take them to the 10th
power that becomes a much bigger
absolute very good well yeah this was a
little bit more challenging but I think
we found the answer
oh no I want you to really stop me in
the next video okay well do that